this video is sponsored by BH hey what
is up guys that could be HD here and
welcome to a bit of a different type of
video my working title for it right now
is just all the gear so this whole thing
this idea started actually a long time
ago back when I was trying a bunch of
different microphones there's a lot of
gear on this channel as you probably
already know but I was just trying a mic
here I'm mic there and I eventually
found the Sennheiser MKH 416 and not a
lot of people not a lot of youtubers are
talking about this mic or reviewing this
mic so just kind of have to pop up for
me
and once I found and started using it I
loved it it's amazing now typically with
a find like this I immediately want to
like use it a bunch and then turn around
and review it and share it with you all
but even with as many of you as our into
tech how many of you are really
interested in a $900 shotgun microphone
like not that many so I sit on it you
know I don't review it but I've been
using it ever since and then this
happened again with the whole process of
a tripod found the sick tripod didn't
really want to review it because how
many people care so I've just been using
it and this process has just been kind
of happening behind the scenes for a
while so this video is a ton of those
things in one place and it's the sort of
stuff that like the video nerd in me has
been itching to share with you guys but
that I haven't had a good reason to make
one video all about any one of these
items now let me just address the
question right off the bat is this
overkill yeah yeah a lot of this stuff
is you can make great videos with a lot
less than this with none of this
honestly and people do every single day
but for my fellow gear heads the next
few minutes are just filled with tips
and gear and things that apply to a very
small number of people I've fully
accepted that almost no one will
actually watch the whole thing or care
about this video but for those of you
who do this is talking through all that
so we can start right off the bat with
this just this set right here just me
talking to the camera you've seen it
before some might call it a roll even a
simple set like this has a bunch of
stuff a bunch of gear I haven't talked
about going on with it so this is that
gear so I can start with the camera
that's sort of the most obvious place
I've talked about these before but these
are Reds dsmcc two bodies
a sensor phenomenal in every way like
they're more camera than I can ever use
but I love them to pieces and they're
amazing so when I'm talking to the
camera like this the lens I'm almost
always using is the Sigma 24 to 35 cine
that's cuz it's a sharp high-quality
wide angle zoom lens that most
importantly covers the full-frame
monstrous sensor there's also a photo
version of course and in a cine world
it's a little cheaper than the
competition but honestly for a lot of
what I do it's actually better it opens
all the way up to t2 it's super sharp I
like it and on the lighting so this is
the sort of lighting look that's been
dialed in so the room of course
is lit with overhead lights there are
5,000 Kelvin just LED overhead lights
nothing special but that's just lighting
the room straight down from the top so
lighting me in this set is a sky panel a
60 C with a 4-foot gigantic softbox on
it its massive but I've gone through a
bunch of different key lights in my time
and this one's turned into my favorite
just because it's so incredibly powerful
and very very soft and it does a bunch
of other things even when it's not the
key light so the C and the name stands
for color and it can make pretty much
any color at any intensity pretty easily
it gets insanely bright right now it's
at less than half brightness and it's a
great key light replacing the Sun and
it's also super heavy so I never really
carried anywhere I pretty much always
have it on wheels so this is basically a
light stand with wheels on it and this
is one of the themes of the studio
actually it's just to put as many things
on wheels as possible
highly recommended there's also one fill
light in this set pretty simple but it's
just off camera and it's just sort of
filling in general brightness of this
set for this high key look and it's an
aperture 300 D so it's actually this is
one of the more well reviewed things on
YouTube from this list you can use it
with or without the light dome diffusion
depending on how soft you want it to be
and it is also on wheels I won't get as
soft as a sky panel I used to use it
mainly as a key light up at the sky
panel is a much bigger source but these
apertures are great value they're pretty
popular for a reason and then there is
audio so obviously video is only half
the story
audio i always under sling so the
microphone is always just a below the
camera right below that sight line and
is this rig right here and it's pretty
flexible I could put the mic almost
anywhere with it but it's a mix pre 6:33
it's the only preamp / recorder I need
to use it's incredible sitting on this
little platform that screws into a
microphone stand and holds it up so I
can see it and it's connected to the mic
I talked about the Sennheiser MKH 416
that shotgun I'm gonna try to link just
about everything I'm talking about
that's useful below if it's available
online it's probably from B&H and
honestly it's because the NH has been
pretty much the go-to place for video
gear for me and has been for a long time
like since before college and they also
happen to be extremely close by they're
in New York City so right across the
river so shipping for me is dangerously
fast and the prices are great and
everything and if I need something right
away I've been known to just go over
there and get it and there's also always
plenty of staff over there willing to
help out so shout out to be an H for
sponsoring this gear tour video and for
carrying this stuff alright so what else
are we noticing in this set pretty
simple back here this is what we call a
little practical light this is a quasar
science four-foot tube it can do RGB
light it can do white light it can do
all sorts of effects if you want it to
it's a four foot tube just sort of
freestanding there
shoutout to Dave to Dee who's the first
one I saw and tech videos anyway using
one I don't know if he uses a quasar
science tube or something else but they
look great I haven't used them to light
any actual subjects yet but they are
awesome as practicals or backgrounds or
sort of effects lights you may even
remember them from the portal intro for
the galaxy s10 display video oh and
right off camera also here's even one
more niche thing that we've used for
videos this is just a BenQ desktop
monitor on a VESA mount on wheels we
call it Karen shout out to Plankton's
girl but it's great for when we're all
looking at the same view for building a
more elaborate set or something we don't
all want to crowd around this small
monitor so plug straight into the camera
via HDMI and that we can all share this
monitor which is just mirroring it in
the future maybe we'll get like a full
on TV on wheels or something but this
has been pretty great too alright then
there is the b-roll which is the
recording of the actual products and
tech and objects instead of the people
which I think I'd do a lot more of and
that's actually where you'll see a lot
more specific gear to do that sort of
thing which brings me to my one of my
favorite lenses ever actually and that
would be the zeiss otus 50
five mil F 1.4 this is a medium lens
it's not really a wide angle but it's
also not super telephoto and it's
incredibly sharp but I will say the one
downside of this lens why I don't use it
even more often than I do is because the
minimum focus distance is a little far
it's almost two feet which is much
further than something like a macro lens
which you can get much closer up to an
object with so that's this this is my
macro lens and probably my third of the
big three of choice the Canon hundred
mil F 2.8 stabilized macro lens so
putting this thing in front of an 8k
sensor will literally let you see things
that your eye doesn't see and it sounds
like I'm exaggerating but it's really
true like I'll put a phone down or
something that looks totally clean with
a microfiber and then I'll zoom in for
focus on this hundred mil and I'll see
all these little flakes of dust and
hairs and I'll have to clean it again
because this picks up every little
detail so this is an amazing lens for
getting smaller detail shots of things
like buttons or tiny objects or things
that you ordinarily wouldn't notice from
being further away and then my
favourites slider right now which
doesn't change very often I've had maybe
three major full-time youth sliders ever
but my current favorite is this guy it's
extremely smooth which a slider should
be and carries a lot of weight this is
called the magic carpet pro by sirrah
the rails are pretty thick it's not belt
driven anymore like my previous favorite
but it is still extremely smooth using
what they call this fly wheel tech and
then on top of all that I think I can
safely call it modular which is actually
pretty useful for a slider so in most
cases when you're doing a lot of small
objects like this you only need two
maybe three feet tops of room to
actually do a slide that's convincing
and fun and makes a small object like
this a little more exciting but if you
have a bigger subject like a car for
example you need much more space to do a
slide like that so being able to add
three feet of track and just keep adding
more and more track just by popping the
ends off is actually really useful and
you can do that with this so that's been
pretty useful as well and then a slider
right now is sitting on this really
unique piece of gear that will call the
pedestal shoutout to John from Tod for
showing me this in the first place it is
a dangerous to go hang out with him and
discover video gear but this thing is
really impressive so I went out to shoot
that auto focused episode on the Tesla
Model 3 in California and when I was
there I was bar
this weird rolling tripod thing but it
could do all these weird camera moves
that I couldn't typically do with a
normal tripod so if you can just imagine
a tripod with wheels at each corner and
then with the structure connecting it
and then a height adjustable base in the
center with crab steering which lets you
turn the wheels and then roll on any
smooth surface so it's also kind of like
a slider that's what this pedestal is
you've seen much bigger versions of this
in like newsrooms
this is much smaller because we use
smaller cameras on but I've used it a
couple times since I've gotten it and
like very specific situations one that
might come to mind is the Apple watch
review there's a floating shot where I'm
checking the time on the watch and
walking down a hallway lose the types of
shots you can't get with really any
other video tool you could try it with a
jib you could try it with a study cam
but yeah you find uses for things with
wheels like this that typically are a
little difficult to come by so this is
why we use the pedestal office so this
really has been one of those specialty
pieces of gear that you sort of figure
out use as for as you go which has been
pretty great but speaking of specialty
yeah Mia is one of those super specialty
things it's a it's a robot holding a
camera and there's 10,000 things you can
do with a robot that you can keyframe
moves into that you couldn't do with a
human so the thing about having a camera
robot as you can see it's such an
extreme unique tool that it is very
tempting to use it all the time I've
talked about this with people in text
and other video makers why don't you use
the robot all the time but then you kind
of get tired of it you'd feel like you
see it all the time and you might
actually take it for granted so it's a
specific challenge of mine to not use
the robot all the time but when we do
use it it is super cool so first of all
not only is this epic w not permanently
but basically all the time mounted onto
the robot we also have a motorized fist
system Fizz being fi z focus iris and
zoom so this 18 to 35 has manual rings
that the robot can also control we also
have a hundred mil macro mapped the same
way is that it can be controlled with
the ring and just like I showed in that
dope tech video back a couple years ago
when we first
discovered this it can be controlled
using an Xbox controller and that's
exactly how we do it there's an iMac
over there running Windows and the
motorized precision software for me to
exactly dial in and keyframe the moves
that we build that you end up seeing in
the videos so the few times you do see a
really crazy looking or interesting or
fascinating move whether it's moving
really fast or you get some sort of
orbital rotation that a human couldn't
do that's because we dreamt up the move
built it using their software and
keyframing and an Xbox controller lit
around it flagged staged made so
everything worked and then pressed
record actually there's a record button
in the software and made it happen and
I'm really glad we have it alright so
next up is the top-down set where we're
at and when I say top-down you can
probably picture the sort of overhead
top down looking sets and as complex as
those can get sometimes the actual gear
setup to make them happen
is pretty simple so we have the light
source over here huge four foot wide
Kino Flo bulbs and they're going through
this white sheet that makes it a very
soft light source and the camera is on
this so this is a Kessler pocket jib Pro
the word pocket a bit of a misnomer cuz
it's kind of already huge but in the
world of jibs this is pretty small
actually so this is the pocket jib Pro
there's a Manfrotto 502 head on it and
then of course the camera pointed
straight down off of that and then the
rest of this is essentially light
control so we can get these looking
consistent in the same way every time so
there's flags there's different
modifiers cutting light at certain
points to make it spread evenly across
this surface and then the surface itself
is kind of a jerry-rigged solution but
it's essentially a bunch of these thin
aluminum sheets that have a vinyl skin a
dbrand skin on them that looks like a
surface or some sort of color and we
have a bunch of these this is the
concrete one it's just a small area that
looks like concrete when you fill it up
in the frame of the top down looks like
you're looking at concrete there's
actually one of those simple setups that
kind of applies to you know you can you
can put any camera in here you can put
any number of different lights in these
positions but generally this rule of
thumb for this simple set up big soft
light source
coming in on top of a surface like this
just looks good alright so some other
small pieces of gear one of my favorites
here is this old vintage manual lens
called the Helios 44 it's a 58
millimeter lens and you can't even buy
them new anymore they're just secondhand
in most cases it's not a sharp lens
there's color fringing and tinting in
various colors it's the opposite of the
technical lens you're used to but what
makes it awesome is it has the most
spirally anamorphic looking bokeh I've
ever seen in a non anamorphic lens so
you'll know it when you see it it showed
up here and there but it's really fun
and this lens is actually really cheap
it's usually like 50 bucks so it's easy
to recommend then there's this
weird-looking lens it's a 15 millimeter
macro tilt shift lens I don't even use
it for the tilt shift part but I swear
to you I'm not exaggerating the minimum
focus distance is literally touching the
front glass so this being such a
wide-angle lens makes it great for
shooting inside cars and things like
that where you're in a tight space and
you're really close to things and then
this guy here is the Canon 11 224 11
millimeters is hilariously wide on a
full-frame sensor but sometimes that's
what you need when shooting inside a car
and this gigantic front element of
course means you can't use ND filters or
anything so I almost never use this lens
outside but it's basically the only lens
I've used to shoot the videos where I'm
talking inside my car then there's a
loud mics so I use a shotgun most of the
time 90 something percent of the time
but sometimes you do need a laugh for a
collab or an interview style type of
thing
these are electro Sonics PDR recorders
you record straight to micro SD cards
and then the second cos 11 D is the name
of the actual mic one for me and one for
Lou or bill or Elan or whoever we need
audio from for that video then this is a
drone this is the DJI and havoc 2 Pro
you've probably seen one of these before
and it looks kind of like a baby
transformer in a weird way when I hold
it like this
but the drone use has been limited but
it's great for top downs of much larger
objects like cars but I want to get
better at using aerial video more in the
future alright some last-second quick
hitters so we get pretty good at knowing
where we can take the red cameras and
where we can I especially know the
weight and size of it and
I can do manual focus and what I can't
but there are certain projects or types
of things where you can't autofocus
videos are number one we tend to stick
to Canon stuff because we're very
comfortable with the colors but their
autofocus is also phenomenal you've
probably heard about dual pixel
autofocus so Canon c200 is the primary
Canon camera we go to when we're not
bringing the red around believe it or
not this is smaller and easier to use it
shoots to real media cards it has a real
long battery life it has an EVF but most
importantly that autofocus so a pretty
decent amount of those car follow shots
that you've seen where we're either
pointing the camera out of window or out
the back of a car at a moving car that's
a good combination of red and c200 so
thanks to c200 for that and it's got the
18 to 35 on it the photo version the
Canon autofocus works pretty great with
any Canon compatible lens so that's
awesome and then Canon 1dx is also
significantly smaller this was my only
camera during Tesla's model Y event back
when I went out to California anytime
you see a vlog style video like that
obviously it has to be an even smaller
camera and also this with a smaller
autofocus lens like a 16 to 35 is great
for a Steadicam anytime you have Ronin s
shots for example the studio tour with
Lou this had a lot of shots from the 1
DX on that run and s also shout-out to
this guy this is called the Westcott
flex and this is exactly what it looks
sounds like it's a flexible a little
light panel that either plugs into the
wall or can be battery-powered we
usually plug it into the wall but this
is what you've seen that's either added
just like a splash of color or a glow in
the background I'll show you some
footage where that's been used and point
out where the Flex is sometimes it's
also even used as a fill light on my
face with a bit of a warmer light since
this is technically a bicolor
2 different color LEDs but the warmer
ones lots is a nice warm splash or as
you can see right now it can be
reflective but we don't actually use it
as a reflector all right I want to say
this is the greatest tripod ever made
but for anyone who's used tripods for a
long time before you're familiar with
the whole like extending the leg and re
tightening it process and it's been
annoying for a long time that's why I
love these but the legs are called the
float X 75 it's a 75 millimeter ball
head so you can put any other 75
millimeter ball head on top I happen to
use another Sackler ball head but the
reason these are amazing
is because the adjustment process is
that so I mean that's basically all I
had to see I saw a couple of videos
about this it's of course it's a carbon
fiber tripod it's lightweight there's
other advantages to it but the main
reason this tripod is so good is because
it's that easy to adjust as soon as I
saw that I got one of them and then I
started replacing my other tripods with
this one because of that so now it's the
only tripod I use alright last but not
least we have arrived at DJI Ronin 2
this whole stabilizer this whole thing
this whole rigs actually just did ug I
run into now I messed around with the
movi for a little bit and it was great
but it was a little smaller and didn't
quite have the battery life I was
looking for Ronin 2 has had a great
battery life and of course having the
whole cage thing and being able to sit
it down wherever you want is great and
it's super modular so we've been able to
set it up exactly how we want based on
what we're shooting with it so two
things that come to mind we've shot with
Ronin 2 number one auto focus videos as
well hanging out the back of an SUV or
on a track with one of these playing in
at an Acura NSX that was rigged one way
but it was rigged a totally different
way with some other accessories when
John was holding it shot up to John
again from TLD when we were doing the
factory tour with Elon Musk that's a
totally different rig to be able to walk
in and out between factories and robots
moving around around you but when it
comes down to it the bottom line is we
use it again for camera movement the
same idea with the pedestal the same
idea with the slider and the whole point
obviously for all this gear stuff that
we've had is to be able to tell a story
or show your visual and a little bit of
a more interesting way now as most of it
overkill yeah I just showed you guys a
camera attached to a robot that does key
framing moves both in the computer
software that kind of stuff is
ridiculous but it is way too much fun
not to share so I figured I would share
it with you yes so even if you're not in
the market to pick up any of this stuff
which probably most of you aren't I hope
you enjoyed watching it and maybe you
learn a thing or two if you enjoyed seen
the type of stuff but this has been the
gear tour thank you for watching
talk to guys the next one peace
but the one downside it has is the
minimum focus distance is a little far
it's almost 2 feet it's one and a half
feet away from the lens which can make
it a little tough to use for macros so I
don't I mean you can get really close to
subject it's basically if you can
imagine yeah yeah I almost bought you